before we say goodbye let's play a quick
round of truth or dare
the cooking segments are my favorite and
i love all your recipes but i was
wondering do you have like a cooking
fail
a cooking fail okay on the show my worst
like
trigger moment of i was with giada de
laurentiis and i learned that if you are
adding parmesan or cheese to your pasta
making like a cacio e pepe
for example
take it off the heat or it will become
snotty cobwebs
and not this beautiful
like thing that it's supposed to be
so
when you are putting cheese in your
pasta
take it off the heat that's that's
something i learned the hard way
and i really wanted to impress her
and i just felt like a total tool bar
but i learned you learned but i think
you should make mistakes in the kitchen
that's why it's there like there's
there's recipes but there are no rules
and you learn from the mistakes so get
in there get your hands dirty and screw
up every once in a while
all right let's get down to business
what's it going to be charlie truth or
dare i want to know what's the longest
either of you have ever gone without
taking a bath
um
i you know that sexy thing people have
when they're like oh they're kind of
dirty and that's hot
yes i do love that smell and i love when
it gets all over a boyfriend's t-shirt
and then you can keep the t-shirt and
like just wear it and snuggle with it in
bed come on you must have had that
experience
i i'm good i shower every day you
understand i know look at him i i i feel
i i believe you ross thank you thank you
i believe it or not don't have that bad
boy musk
what about you how long do you go
without taking a shower here's the deal
i can totally not wash my hair for like
a week in fact the natural oils like
rocket little dry shampoo but i can't go
that long with the body like i that is
where i draw the line like i've gone to
wash me bits you know yeah i gotta keep
it clean
um and then i wash my face two to three
times a day minimum understood so it's
like the hair i can let that go for a
week but the face and the body is
it's a it's a regular thing yeah but you
like your guys to have a little funkadoo
i want that bad boy musk yeah you do how
is that not a perfume
can i name a candle after that what
which one funkadoo no bad boy mud bad
boy musk yeah yeah that's way better
yeah that's so i find that cam
i have i just created the perfect set
for it i'm going to bring it to you
tomorrow and you're going to smell it
okay yeah i want to make my own candles
right now so i have i'm we're creating
all these fragrances and there's this
one where i'm like this is sex it's so
hot it's so such a turn-on
and
it's been a long time yeah
sorry
all right what's it going to be a truth
or a dare it's going to be a juice okay
so what's one thing that you love to do
is there were zero consequences
[Laughter]
mine's so boring do you wanna know what
truly what it is it's really the honest
truth is i would eat like all the pizza
i could because i broke up with pizza it
was a great thing while it lasted but
i'm not doing it anymore and i just
haven't eaten it in so long and because
the consequences i'm allergic to it it
makes my body swell you understand
[Laughter]
i mean do you guys know the movie
defending your life it's an albert brook
it's so meaningful it's just one of my
favorite all-time movies and in it when
they go into the you know purgatory
um basically you get to eat anything you
want without gaining any weight yeah
yeah that's the dream yeah so i not to
be boring but i might piggyback on you
yes
if i could eat without consequence
that's all i want yeah
my metabolism is that of a sloth on a
very heavy dose of value
and it's just that sloth is like a sleep
at the switch i eat one doughnut and
i've got like a giant doughnut popping
out of my skin if i smell a cheese puff
10 pounds
totally i am like a human pendulum so
eating without consequence would be
everything
[Music]